in part two with my chat with Mark
Cartier from the shuttlepod show we
really get stuck in to a lot of things
Star Trek and Stargate we discuss some
really toxic fandom and our hopes for
the new Stargate franchise
don't forget to go and check out part
one of this chat but more importantly go
and subscribe to the shuttlepod show the
link is in the description Anson wood
[Music]
he clearly has You by 50 pounds like
the guy Anson looks like he's 6'4 and
Kirk actor looks mostly half
yes
only Star Trek show out of the new track
that I've got up early to watch before I
go to work sort of thing
Star Trek uh Picard season three is the
first Star Trek where Erica was like are
we gonna go watch it can we want are we
watching it tonight
[Music]
I have this I have this love-hate
relationship with uh time travel and
Alternate timelines because they're
always terrible
but sometimes they're fun and you get
like the Voyage Home there's very
few ultimate timeline there were times
that
that work when they work they're
brilliant there's a Groundhog Day
episode of Stargate which is the
greatest I can never forgotten the title
yeah embarrassing
um but it's the greatest episode of
sci-fi
it's just it's just incredible there's a
number of
um time problem Stargate episodes in SGU
and sg1 that are my favorite episodes of
Television ever because I think they
deal with them in a really intriguing
way
and it almost always ends with our Prime
Stargate team looking at it and being
like well I guess we won't do that
oh yeah the Mirror Universe at the end
of them season two it was exactly that
Apophis was attacking and they got to
the emergency unit and it was that was
the whole way that the season
that kickstarted into the next season
and it was that was when it took a new
level to me when Stargate really kicked
off
um but um but when it's yeah when it's
done badly I think Star Trek has done it
badly at times and that's the problem is
that
the couple of episodes when they've gone
back in time and it's been okay but
normally but I say that it's Enterprise
my favorite Enterprise episode is
regenerations and that was the episode
that spun off from nemesis
um not necessary first Contact and the
Borg were found there was a research
um thing yeah
I love that episode it's such a great
episode of Star Trek
um and you know it's just
that was a time travel episode and I
loved it kind of so
um but when they when they get when it's
wrong though it's bloody awful
it's just to me it's like there's a
mechanism in storytelling called DSS
makina you know got in a box and it's
like God in the machine and um got on
the machine usually is usually a
reference to when a story gets so
complicated that it requires God coming
out of the sky
on a stage in a machine uh and coming
down and sorting it all out for us
teaching us just telling us what the
lesson is and then the play is over
um that's what time travel is to me in a
lot of the Star Trek stuff
yeah when it's a device used so that you
can tell the story you want to tell as
opposed to something integral
I I mean like the what was the first
time travel story was it was it a city
in the engine forever
oh in Star Trek yeah
it must have been because yeah going
through the the guy that the guardian
what's it called the gates yeah
that thing ended up in uh discovery
which was yeah I thought I love that
thanks uh
[Music]
Guardian forever that's right
yeah we all are guardians of forever
yeah I love the answer they got to do it
for thinking he's such a like I can't I
can't remember his name he's like a
blackter he's brilliant everything he
goes I think he was he not no he was not
I was gonna say I think he's in was in
the episode where uh Janeway wins the
continuum but I think it was a different
action it was the guy from Battlestar
Galactica that's right yeah
um
anyway uh I I hear what you're saying
re-watchability of Picard C I haven't
rewatched season three because
I'm afraid that it's not gonna be as
good re-watching it
I think the relief of having good Star
Trek was uh
part of what made it so good I mean
because I knew the Enterprise D was in
that damn hunger I knew it so I called
it oh my God I actually
I really believed that they were gonna
because they were like oh all the ships
have been you know
interfaced uh we have to find an old
ship one that is an interface I thought
they were gonna go get the Enterprise a
or the you know the
original Enterprise or the Voyager
because they made such a big deal out of
the Voyager I was like oh my God they're
gonna steal the Voyager and they're
going to save the world with the Voyager
how cool is that
we actually said I wonder if there's
going to be the whole Fleet
so it's like all the museum Fleet yeah
basically chips oh my God
the uh Enterprise a the nor the original
Enterprise the Voyager the oh that
would have been great because I mean
they made such a big day out of some of
the ships that were there as well
um that I thought well they're going to
do the whole Fleet and that will be cool
because then he like this this actually
is like a fleet versus flee and it makes
sense and then when they actually just
did the deal I was like
I'm just gonna work and then it did
actually the um the Millennium Falcon
bit going into the cube and yeah and I
did love that bit with data
yeah why am I sensing this building is
enjoying themselves
um but I I got irritated I said don't
watch it again
no don't don't do it you get yourself a
glass get yourself
[Music]
something else
don't watch it again because uh for me I
I watch it a bit more critically because
I feel like is it really is because
obviously I've got a Sci-Fi channel so I
have to talk about these things is it
really is good and I watch it back and
I'm like I've found myself watch playing
on my phone I just stopped watching it
really irritated at stupid things stupid
mistakes in it and I was like so I'm
like oh man I've come and spoiled the
best Star Trek for years for myself what
an idiot so now I'm thinking of maybe I
need to watch it again
and but without thinking something I
just don't think about it I have a
theory cool I think he watched it too
quickly
quite possibly I think you watch it
again too soon after you watch it the
first time I think you need to let it
sit
and go back and watch it yeah well I
mean I did that with Enterprise I was
not the biggest fan of Enterprise when
it came out I was um I hate prequels
I hate all of them
um generally speaking they they do pee
on Canon they I I always think it's like
we already know what happens
so you know it's like so where's the
threat
where's the you know where's the we we
in strange new worlds is the same
problem we kind of know you know what
happens because of the original series
and references from TNG so I'm like so
they're actually now manufacturing this
battle with the Gorn
so the gaun and now the villain because
they know they can't really do anything
else because we already know what
happens so I'm like so what's the point
Enterprise
that's not that's not fair I didn't like
how Enterprise ended because I always
thought it was going to be how was the
Federation created and it never really
did that it got bogged down with the
with the time Wars and Cold War and
things
I didn't like the zindy thing
I didn't mind the Cindy I didn't like it
um I love the attack they did I did I
did enjoy the the first bit and I
enjoyed the battle at the end there was
a lot of good stuff in there but it was
um I don't know
but you know I'm very much all track is
good trick and uh I will never if I had
to choose
anything else in Star Trek I will choose
Star Trek uh it doesn't matter what
series it is
I think I said this I can't think what
it was now I think I've said this about
strange new rules and I I didn't like
the way it ended and I was just like so
you don't like it there's no no I still
loved it yeah I love it it's just it's
like compared to other Star Trek but
don't compare to anything else because
it's still better than almost everything
else that's on telly yes but it
disappointed me because it's got to
start the title you and I can have this
kind of conversation where we're into
the minutia I don't want anyone watching
this to think that for a second I don't
like any Star Trek because I love
All-Star trip so no we're getting into
it more personal preferences of how if
if I was in charge of the show or if you
were in charge of the show this is what
we would have preferred um yeah and it's
because we love that these things matter
if I didn't love the show it wouldn't
matter that they make a silly mistake
about you know the the the the bloody
Parton Picard season three that the um
changeling jumped in and I'm just like
why is it got residue
and and there's just things like that
and I'm sort of like if if I didn't love
it it wouldn't bother me
but it bothers me because I love it oh
you just don't want Oda to have been
leaving goo behind well yeah exactly
what was gross he's like he's not Slimer
all of a sudden from Ghostbusters I mean
what the hell
um but I mean it is gross yeah yeah well
listen you would have uh Diana Troy's
mother luwaksana would have had goo on
her dress
yeah yeah that's that's true
um I like the Orville when there's the
goo thing the other one character that's
like a big snot and um he makes love to
the doctor and the doctor I'm just like
I always wonder if that's like a
changeling it's not the changeling from
the changelings do rompy bumpy
um Odo like do you want a bit more
but um
I
I think the thing is like with Stargate
at the moment with potentially getting a
Revival which were hopefully getting
announced soon fingers crossed
um
it's really dangerous because this this
is like with um Stargate first time
around to do sg1 he did SGA and then
they did SGU which was completely
different and fans didn't like it even I
didn't like it oh my point about
Enterprise was sorry I watched it back
years later and loved it I loved
everything I thought it was great
Scott Bakula was brilliant in it and I
was just well I found out Scott Bakula
was going to be
um Captain I was just like that is the
greatest bit of casting ever that's
genius he's he's okay I just wanted to
go oh boy just once that was only my
only issue
um but then
um so SGU was very very different and
I've always thought though
if they'd have done another SGA sg1 and
SGA I know Joe Flanagan said they were
very different shows
I'll discuss that with him they weren't
they were very similar in lots and lots
of ways
um the formula the way the form the way
they were set up sort of thing SGU was
completely different in every single way
um
but the thing is fans didn't like that
but if they'd just done another SG one
SGA sort of
showing doing the same again
um it's just like you're damned if
you're doing damned if you don't
disorder
um I loved SGU to be perfectly honest I
know there's a lot of annoying
like forced politics thins in the vein
of Battlestar Galactica where it was
like okay this is
this is not realistic I and I
derogatorily call it Canadian filmmaking
uh it seems like all these Canadian
shows have that sort of forced political
heavy-handed terrible ADR bad sound
design sort of dramaturgy going on
um there was a whole thing going on with
the switch to HD at that time where they
could run around with cameras on their
shoulder because you you know it didn't
weigh 80 pounds anymore and you will
play with the focus the digital Focus
pull so you know all that you know rack
Focus and zoom Focus stuff to just
kind of drama
um
dramatically
manufactured yeah Battlestar Galactic
was great I love that show but so much
of it was like a little heavy-handed it
was a little manufactured it's like all
right I get it not boring towards the
end battle stuff it's like okay how many
times can you have some political
horseshit like about like
uh
that's the problem
I don't know how to say this
uh
I loved SGU it's like I love Battlestar
Galactica in fact SGU is quite possibly
my favorite show if you take Star Trek
out of the conversation
um because what it got right it got
really right and what I got wrong wasn't
so unprecedented and like it it wasn't
walk away from the show worthy uh they
were trying to create friction that just
weren't doing it very well
um in my my opinion uh uh
I do agree with a lot of fans statements
uh you know we got a lot of comments
when we had David blue on
anyone again about SGU uh and how the
everyone was hateable
so it wasn't a likable character in it
uh David Blues character except yeah
generally people like liked Eli yeah
um and it's like yeah I get it sure I
really love the communication stones but
I think they it up
yeah they use them too much they use
them too much there was no consequence
using them and uh it was for you know
like
the whole thing between young and uh La
Bamba and um
uh Young's wife even when young was
having a baby with Johansen it was like
ah come on
it's not I don't know I just it's so
much of it was very forgettable from the
first season
um you'd forget Ming now win was it
um yeah because she was terribly
utilized especially in the first season
such a great actress as well but that
was the thing I was going to say SGU the
first season I was doing poorly that's
what it was SGU had like a mustache
twirly super villain sort of vibe to it
where everyone was like I'm going to
manipulate you
come on Rush I know I know something you
don't like you're all on a spaceship
you're on an ancient ship
50 000 galaxies away or whatever the
hell it is and uh you guys are still
playing politics like you're working at
you know huge Co
uh in in somewhere in the United States
like
come on no one cares about your politics
when you're desperate to survive
um I think if they'd focus on Survival
over
uh Power politics
uh it would have been better
well so I just thought it was there was
elements of it that were just boring
because they did again they did they
they were trying to copy Battlestar
Galactica
that's just that's you can't help it but
a lot of the stuff was like we need to
find water we need to distribution and
it goes it's a little boring but um so I
watched it again recently because I've
actually said I've I've
it's still better than 90 of stuff on
there but compared to se1 SGA I don't
like SGU and comparatively
um yeah like I would watch every episode
of SGU before I would watch a single
episode of sg1 season one see that I was
just gonna say
first season of SGU wasn't very good but
it was getting loads better by the end
of season two but the first season one
wasn't very good
was just
no money
absolutely no money at all they were
skint they were trying to find their the
first episode the first season of TNG
wasn't great
um compared to TNG was terrible yeah
they
um they killed off tashiya they some for
some reason Jordan laforge suddenly got
engineering skills
um and Wharf became the the security
chief that they would have done and the
show just kicked on from there but the
first season when they're trying to find
their feet was Bloody awful yeah I just
think
virtually every show I love except maybe
like X-Files the first season's the best
season of that but no shows on the first
season they always take a minute the
best shows take a minute to get on their
feet
yeah uh season three is usually when
they hone it in
um I have a very unpopular opinion about
TNG and why the first season sucked and
people are me saying that out loud is
gonna anger people
um it didn't suck it's just not my
favorite
um and I think it struggled
because
Gene ronberry and he's admitted this
many times in interviews to people who
have been on our show
uh
kind of saw TNG as just
an extension of the Original Series yeah
he the original series he loved
uh he felt it was cut short and he's I
think he's right yeah yeah 100 and when
he got a chance to do the Next
Generation
uh he wanted to
basic basically carry on with what he
was doing with the original series
just with a new cast
uh and so it there's so many
similarities similarities between season
one and TOS uh that uh I don't think
anyone can argue that but when I've said
something similar in the past on our
show you know the comments lit up and
everyone's like oh with you you're
such a you don't know anything Jana
Troy's uniform
yeah right back to the original season
and then my story lines just visual
stuff like that
um but rugby was such a I remember a
story I heard that um the executive
producers and they weren't going to fund
to build the set of the engine room
is like if they don't build it straight
away I won't get it so he rewrote the
pilot to have a scene with the engine
rooms they've had to build the energy
building and just think about his his
vision like that it's just like but I I
thought you mean that there are certain
episodes they're just original but then
they have an episode like conspiracy
and you just go
where'd that come from are we watching
oh yeah there is a I did a video on that
years ago and I did a joked sort of like
um it was so unfederation they were like
that thing comes out of his mouth and
and instead of like um normal Federation
let's explore let's try to talk this
through they're like oh no like it
and um
but it was such a standout episode that
was when I think I I fell in love with
TNG I think runberry was one of the most
amazing Visionaries uh we've ever had in
storytelling his legacy what he created
has look what it's become it's the
single largest franchise quite possibly
in the history of Storytelling modern
style Star Wars really isn't it but Star
Wars it's like you know in Star Wars is
Star Wars but
it had the hours of content compared to
Star Trek it's not as close
it's like still a child comparison
completely different one's fantasy one
sci-fi they are different but yeah I
have this argument with my wife which
one's better if she's a Star Wars fan
and I'm a Trekkie and I'm just like yeah
but Star Wars I love Star Wars but again
if I had to choose if there was a Star
Trek movie playing at the theater and a
Star Wars movie playing at the theater I
would pay for the Star Trek ticket and I
would sneak into the Star Wars movie
never been a big fan of Star Wars I
watch it but I don't obsess on it and
we've got um Miss glad Harris I said
that it comes on our show the American
blood he's he's obsessive he knows every
character he knows everything and it's
like
I don't care he goes on what he goes on
rants sometimes uh oh this has happened
with this character and I think in Clone
Wars oh God but then he'll mention
something about dalitian crystals and
I'm like right I really liked the Han
Solo movie just saying that you liked
Han Solo the the movie they did
you're the only one I loved it you're on
your own
that would matter if it was
it was I liked it
I can't remember damn thing from that's
always mine so the yardstick
if you ask me afterwards what happened
if I can't tell you I didn't enjoy it
and uh I'll tell you what happened in it
I can remember bits I remember the sort
of like her and
um
the woman from Game of Thrones arguing
on a planet somewhere I just think
they're cast solo wrong if I'm honest
they just got the casting wrong
but um
yeah I don't know I like them
um I think they changed directors and
stuff as well halfway through or
something I don't think
yeah but it was it yeah it didn't work
for me I loved Andor I thought andal was
great I think Rogue one is one of the
best things that's been done in years I
thought it was absolutely amazing but
um
[Music]
Dennis I don't worry about
um so Venice is that is that that's the
thing with all the canals isn't it oh
man that's I always like I love that
when it's on TV shows and you see that
they're jumping over the water and those
and there was no that area yeah
[Music]
we're right on the water
um the ocean is right here
and we're a block away from the the
famous Venice sign
beautiful I've got a caravan in North
Wales what you say which is where all
the hills are in England it's not part
of England it's the country next England
um but that's where I spend most my
weekends and I just adore it
um I keep doing videos up there and I'm
like walking past the beach and stuff
and people was like you know people seem
quite like it but um
but I was going to ask you something but
just before we head off because I've got
to go to bed
what was I going to ask you
I wanted to ask you I want to tell you
that I watched your recent video
about Stargate and you were talking with
about the pop cast guys
assessment of the new show and um we've
talked about it a bit already but I want
to be really clear like
I think the negative assessment that
some executive is going to kill a
potential new Stargate show or movie
before
anything has even been announced is uh
uh toxic fandom I think it's uh not good
for
them it's not good for us it's not good
for this franchise
why would you on it before it even
started like
we're not going to oh you your analysis
was
if you
are concerned and vocal about it being
terrible you're going to make it
terrible you're going to find a way for
it to be terrible that's just basically
I was really surprised to hear that
their analysis was negative because I
really like those guys I'm a big fan of
their shows I've been on the show
um I think they're great
uh so it kind of surprised me that they
were
sometimes again through Twitter they are
seem really nice guys we've shared a
little bit of um I don't think because
um
I I say I kept sharing stuff about
Stargate that nobody else had I was
talking that was telling people Brad
Wright isn't going to be involved nearly
two years ago and things like this
because I I did a video that turned out
to be wrong
but a guy actually messaged me saying
that's wrong but he was so specific on
why it was wrong I started chatting to
him it turns out he worked at MGM at the
time he doesn't know he work somewhere
else now but he worked on gym at the
time so he introduced me and got me and
I started talking to a few people and I
started to get all this nice bits of
information about Stargate
um so they were really lovely about it
because they did a video about it and
they completely said look this guy's
been at it from beginning they thought
this is something this so we we started
chatting sort of thing and they're
really nice guys
um and I have told them I think you just
because I told them I was going to do
that video because they it it upset me
quite a bit I was just like this is I
hate this
um but actually apparently Amazon are
very aware of it or um a company that
does some of their marketing is quite
aware of it and they called it um they
don't want to rings of power it
and and I was sort of like and that's
apparently now becoming a term
um because there was so much hate built
up about rings of power beforehand
people
had already decided they didn't like it
six months before it was released and
I I just I just can't have it it's just
it's not and anyway the argument that
Amazon destroyed everything it touches
it's just bogus it's just not true it's
bogus the expanse is amazing there's a
lot of Amazon it's really good
they're a reasonably new studio yeah
they produce a lot of stuff through
other people and show me one at one
Studio ever that's just hit done hit
after hit that's just what what a lot of
uh fandom doesn't understand is uh
probably three quarters of anything
that's branded as an Amazon original was
actually something that was
independently financed and acquired by
Amazon and contractually
put the Amazon original logo on it yeah
it was something Netflix was doing
before that as well they were
um sort of uh
static stuff it was
it was done as Netflix original here
um they took the they removed the CBS
stuff the couple of first couple of
Seasons Discovery it said Netflix
original over and now here it says Prime
original all over um Picard because they
are Finance didn't it basically but
that's because until about six months
ago Amazon didn't own any Studio space
they are none
um here in Culver City they're on the
old Culver City Studios they um they've
just reopened litty um I think they've
got about six Studios there now on the
Culver City six stages yeah yeah so um
but until it might have been a bit more
than six months ago now I'm still on
covid brain but it was quite recently
that those actually opened and they
started using them and I think it sounds
days 15 they've just literally just
filmed their first movie there
um world's largest virtual Sound Stage
apparently it's got two massive LED
screen TV I've seen it
that just blows my mind I'm just like
that can't work and I've but I've seen
some images from it and I'm like that
really works I want Amazon to work well
because one I'm always going to be an
Amazon Prime member because I
I order a lot of stuff from Amazon yeah
I was asking if you're a business I do I
go oh you're a business would you like a
business account because no I don't buy
a lot of crap from you
uh but also Amazon is doing the Fallout
TV show and I told you before we started
this conversation that I'm a big
follow-up
yeah my video game is falling should be
so good have you seen some of the first
images
I have I'm trying really hard not to see
too much of it I don't want to get all
like Fanboy into every single detail and
every single speculative tidbit
um yeah
I think I would like to wait for the
show to get released and then just enjoy
it with a clean slate and have not
completely my expectations into
the ground yeah
the two Studios that seem to actually be
doing stuff at the moment that are
exciting though is like Netflix is seems
to be back in its game I think it's it's
had a couple of years where it's not
done some great stuff
or some of the stuff coming looks
exciting but and
um Amazon they're the ones that are
doing things like
um
the um the Henry Cavill show
the um and I'm sorry doing god of war
and
um Warhammer and all these sort of
things and almost like God of War in
particular that should be incredible
that's the Amazon that's the um expanse
guys doing that and um they've done the
development work for it and I can't wait
I know those guys we had a couple of TV
shows with them
well that was the rumor that Mark Fergus
pushed for Stargate that he was um the
early favorite to get the Stargate
franchise but it went very quietly
apparently they were having
conversations with him before Christmas
and then they sort of stopped
so and that was the last I heard and um
so I have no idea what's going on with
it now I don't care what form or fashion
Stargate comes back as
I will be there to watch it oh hell yeah
uh I am a huge fan of Stargate and I
would really love
for
our community to be optimistic about it
that'd be nice it's very easy for us to
on this stuff now because we are so
disappointed and this goes back to what
I was saying earlier
um motion picture studios television
networks have turned into tech companies
speculative tech companies
and tech companies are not the motion
picture business
uh Studios and we talk about this a lot
on our show uh motion picture studios
and television networks are no longer
run by filmmakers and television makers
they're run by lawyers and they're run
by
um uh dbas
um
what is a business management
degree holder I'm a business mbas yeah
uh lawyers and mbas run Studios and
networks now and uh they don't carry a
pedigree of a lifetime of
um success and failures and the Art of
Storytelling uh they
know how to manipulate spreadsheets and
that is not storytelling and I think we
are all suffering right now because of
it
I think
you're right but I also think we're
suffering an element of
quantity over quality I think there's
there's been an open 100 million yeah
there's been an open streaming War over
the last five years in particular
um particularly with Disney plus they
went we are going to just outspend
Netflix and we're going to catch them up
um and so they just produced loads of
Marvel they produce loads of Star Wars
and and also and
it's suffered for Marvel in particular
seriously suffered because they just
tried to release three films a year and
three four two TV series and they're
just
weren't good enough
um you can tell by the special effects
in the CGI that the the art Department
was just overrun they just couldn't keep
up
um
across the board I'll tell you actually
another studio is doing really well the
mountain is actually you're all going to
be Paramount I think I've just got
Paramount plus recently and there's some
good stuff on that show I've just
started watching um rabbit hole with uh
yeah I think it's a bloody brilliant
series always end up binging four
episodes last night just because we
started watching it and then couldn't
stop I think Paramount plus and Apple tv
Plus
are the two premium content creators
right now yeah apple I'm making some
yeah some that they're very much quite a
quality they are quality over quantity
yeah nothing like enough
yeah yeah it is almost not enough we I
mean we have officially watched all of
Apple TV's content and it's like now
what yeah I'll still pay for it because
something else will come out
um but it's yeah there's there's nothing
on there really but what they release is
all great so no no that they are doing
well but um yeah I think the streaming
was I just think
they just try to do too much too fast
and well excited about being Tech Bros
but you know girl
it's a whole okay go make your app leave
us alone Yeah well yeah but I think
Warner Brothers have got the right idea
at the moment though is they've they've
sort of gone right instead of trying to
actually fight all these guys let's just
work with them so now they're doing
projects for everybody they're doing
projects for accoladian projects for
Netflix uh so the head of wetv is a
woman named Channing Dungey who was the
president of ABC and ABC was really good
at producing content on top of
um just uh above and beyond its own
network so they would produce shows that
would be available on other networks and
other platforms and they're doing that
at WBTV right now
um I think that WB I think you're right
WB is doing a good thing where they're
producing content that releases on other
forms or in other distribution
um uh
uh streams or Roots
um
but I think that uh
uh WBTV is also sort of strangled at the
moment with
Discovery took over Warner Brothers and
um
they've been manhandling HBO a little
bit and I think one I think it was a
mistake to call HBO to call wb's TV
streaming service HBO Max I get that wh
is the Premier brand at WB but if you
called it WB plus and you were able to
include HBO and the other
uh you know Brands under that family of
uh whatever
um probably would have branded better
um well it's not just max
now it's just max so they've gone away
from the drop the HBO but they've also
instead of preserving HBO's premium
content status uh the new uh bosses from
Discovery have said HBO is no longer in
the business
of creating uh premium expensive
experimental content and it's like
that's all HBO's ever done yeah that was
what high school's famous for that was
like famous for that's why they're HBO
yeah
that's right yeah there's like shock
content and to a point and well things
like The Sopranos nobody else was really
doing things like that yeah and
change the
of Television The Sopranos did
uh HBO is responsible for changing how
television was made yeah
I think most of the discovery is so used
to like oh but we make Ash loads of
money on reality TV so we're gonna save
money and we're gonna make money and
it's like no you're not not on this
scale
you're gonna if you take away
what why people watch HBO
they're gonna go
to Apple or Paramount or Amazon or
Netflix
uh who will make
giant budget experimental television
like The Sopranos like uh Lord of the uh
not Lord of the Rings uh uh I'm a dragon
Game of Thrones yeah
um and hacks of the dragon and yeah
yes which is how should the dragon is
now not it doesn't feel like a HBO show
anymore
The Game of Thrones became so popular it
took out like boobs and stuff and
towards the end but this is like it's
like I could let my kids watch House the
Dragon
and I was like that's not like that HBO
show that's not right I don't I don't
want to watch it if my kids can
yeah
I I don't really want to watch this did
you ever watch the um
it got so popular they took up boobs
yeah they took them boobs
um did you watch the Spartacus show on
Stars I actually had a hard time with it
I watched a little bit of it and I was
like ah this is just gratuitous like
that right in my gym yeah I'm sure I
watched it and I actually really enjoyed
it but every time I watched it at the
end of the episode I'd have a moment I'm
never watching this again such
ridiculous stupid stupid um cartoosis
violence gratuitous sex with you to
swear and this is just stupid
when's it on next week
and it became like a really guilty
pleasure watching it but it was too much
it went too far and and The Game of
Thrones went too far a couple of times
the Red Wedding and things like that you
watch it then so I don't think that was
too far I think that too far for Game of
Thrones was really early on with the
sword in the baby belly I mean there
were two brother and sisters sex
partners going on in that Journey
Jamie Lannister which I get agree for
and yeah that was yeah and he pushes the
kid off the thing in the first series
you know but
um when the the um the mountains forget
that happens yeah so early on everything
else after it was quite tame compared to
that it was in the pilot yeah but um the
Red Wedding it was just the the sword
into the baby's belly that got me
um you never saw that I'm telling you
know little kids never die
um you know it's like um it was like the
first episode of Battlestar Galactica
that's the bit the just the mini series
for me was perfect it was just the
series I got a bit boring towards the
end but the mini series was phenomenal
um but the thing was the the tall blonde
silence snapped the baby's neck and was
just like
you don't get that in TV what's what the
hell am I watching
um but it it worked I mean that was done
more subtly than anything Game of
Thrones if it did but um but yeah it was
yeah I Love Game of Thrones but it's
become tame and I'm not and I'm enjoying
house the dragon I did enjoy the first
season of the house
but um I had a fight with one of the
executives on Game of Thrones so I
refused to watch it I only watched it
because
the last season was so hyped I was like
fine I'll watch it so I binged all of
Game of Thrones so that I could watch
the last season
and I was like okay I've seen it no I'm
not gonna go back all right was that um
actually because you then did all of
that to watch the worst bits of games oh
yeah I got the last season I was like
what the am I watching yeah so like
a normal American yeah normally American
TV shows are obsessive with last time on
and I've always said that Game of
Thrones really desperately needed uh and
I I hate it I'm just like some American
TV shows I watch sometimes I'm like
after an advert they'll go last time on
I'm like no it was two minutes ago I
remember minutes ago yeah
um I remember last week it's fine but
Game of Thrones I need to be there with
like a tape recorder like going just
remember this bit this bit was
everything with it or like a notepad and
Pen I really needed it last time on so
many characters so many stuff I couldn't
keep up I've watched it three times now
I still don't know after what was going
on
um but in a good way because it was a
good show but I loved it
[Music]
um
but before we head offline because I do
have to go to work tomorrow at some
point it's 11 though yeah it's way late
for you isn't it oh yeah I've got to
help people tomorrow 11 in the evening
there yeah yeah it's cool and I'm old
smash so I'm I'm like I'm some kind of
like a you know oh I'm probably older
than you yeah I know I don't like his
Uncle by um nine o'clock I got a bit of
a baby because I'm actually 45 but I got
a bit of a baby face so I get away with
okay you met me by a year and a half
then
my code for uh my past card at work and
we use that for a past card to get into
our computers and it's our date of birth
it was 1978 for me and um I learned it
this girl had forgotten her card so she
took it off and went uh what's your code
on 1978. I don't work for anymore so
that's fine
um why she was 1978 when that's not your
request and I'm just like you're my new
favorite person yeah yeah
unfortunately though this morning Erica
was like no no you're not 43.
you're 40. I was like no I'll be 44 in a
couple of months and I'm certainly not
40. I've got old enough now that am I
insisted I was 42 not long ago and I
wasn't joking I was I genuinely believed
I was 42 and the wife was still like why
did you just lie about your age and I
said what do you want oh yeah oh Jesus
I'm older than that yeah
um but but yeah
um so you were gonna ask before you run
off to Old Man's sleep I can't remember
aren't we just a couple of old guys just
losing our minds and forgetting going
gray and
um I said because I can't grow a beard
that's why I look young Never Enough
grumpy
um but before you head off what so what
what are you watching at the moment then
what is what is the TV that is getting
you excited at the moment
uh
well strange new worlds has me excited
I'm really happy with it I like it a lot
I'm a big fan
uh
the show that uh Eric and I just
finished watching last night was high
desert on Apple TV plus with Patricia
Arquette
yeah if I've seen that it's very bizarre
it's very eccentric she's like this
I just think as soon as I said producer
rocket I'm like that's gonna be
she plays like this um uh this woman
who's struggling with staying off uh of
drugs she's she does all the party drugs
and she's trying to stay out of it and
her mother has just died and her life is
at a crisis point and she tries to
reinvent herself as a private
investigator with a very good friend
uh uh
Everyone Loves Raymond's brother what is
his name
uh
very funny very tall American comedian
actor who was the brother and everyone
loves Raymond anyway it doesn't matter
um I think he plays a private
investigator who's losing his business
and she sort of cons her way into
solving a murder it's very very
um
unexpected very funny
uh
very intense and also very sort of
Chatty and uh eccentric
um
oh it we've realized at the LA the last
episode we watched was the last episode
ever which was so it was just it was a
cliffhanger and I was like oh damn it no
then they canceled it yeah I loved it it
was so good uh we we watched the entire
first season just in the last few days
so uh
High Desert on Apple TV is great
I've got Apple TV because it's Ted lasso
um and
um a few other things so I got new Apple
phones they give me a year for free what
okay
for that year ends until I've started
watching today
um um and I I kind of think that the
political
scenery in America
um is it chuckled um The Newsroom
I love the show
it's so good I think I canceled after
two didn't I think three yeah
um but I've just started I've literally
to the fourth or fifth episode in and
they were talking about the Republicans
in the Tea Party elements I think and
all the way through I'm just watching it
thinking I wish this had got through to
Trump this would have been so good
[Laughter]
[Music]
it was the guy that did Boston Legal
which is Alicia I absolutely adored
um with Bill shallow yeah but Bill
Shannon who we're gonna get on our show
God damn it if it kills you or are you
actually getting money no so I I found
um I've been uh dealing with his
publicist and
um I I found out just this last week
that his agent is a guy I know and have
done business with before and I was like
you've got to be kidding me how did I
not know this so uh I'm really excited
about making it happen but
um
[Music]
is that who's who have you got coming on
this weekend or if you've got another
moment to plug it with my fans at least
yeah this Sunday we're doing um well I
don't know what day your episode This is
Gonna release but it'll well I was gonna
have to go out in parts now because
we've been talking for two hours
uh today is Tuesday July 11th so the uh
this Sunday we are doing a another live
stream we're gonna watch another episode
of Star Trek uh this will be our second
time doing it live so we've worked out a
lot of The Kinks and we think it'll be a
lot more fun uh but we enjoyed it a lot
and the fans seem to of our show seem to
really like it so we're gonna do another
one this Sunday we're going to do a lot
of uh fan questions we're going to talk
about Star Trek and we're gonna have an
agenda this week
and then next week uh we're gonna have a
regular the shuttlepod show
guest it's going to be Dr Muhammad Noor
who is uh uh a Star Trek consultant uh
who's very well known in the fandom he
goes to the conventions he picks up the
conventions and on the cruises and all
that and
uh he's gonna sort of introduce our show
to the world of uh Star Trek inspired
science or science inspired Star Trek
and uh yeah we hope to have other
science guests on like astronauts and
like the woman who drives the Mars rover
and uh
stuff like that it's amazing how many
fans how many I didn't say scientists
like um what's his name Tim
the British astronaut Tim
ET but anyway it was a huge Trekkie and
all these sort of things and um I I got
to which is why I'm so annoying that I
can't remember his name
because I met him and he's my friend
he's my closest friend and I can't
remember his name Yeah Tim something but
anyway
um he was such a look I just met him he
was just after he got back he was
everywhere for a couple of years
um
Timothy Nigel Peak Tim Peake I want to
say Tim Peake but I think that's not
right but it was it's Tim Peak there you
go yeah
um so
um and I I just asked him because I
actually said to him I do a Sci-Fi show
because I watch talk about Star Trek and
that was in there for 15 minutes I'm
pretty sure that's great
they just kept going on about our thing
and he didn't like
um
uh oh he said about how Enterprise
I start the conversation you should
watch it again because that should
loaded better than this this and this
um and and he was just like oh okay
maybe I'll give him the go and it was
just he was just lovely but he just
wouldn't shut up I was like all right
I'm on board now I want to walk away now
it's not like it's like I met Dave Grohl
and all I did was shout Dave at him and
um
so I need to get better at meeting
famous people
one day
and then the the other one that we've
been working on for a while and we've
been we're hoping to have this month uh
is Terry mattalis
that will go that one should be
interesting it will be interesting yeah
um because I mean I
I'm not as massive I I think there's a
lot of people in the fandom that think
terminality is now the second coming of
Jesus is the savior yeah yeah I I'm not
as enamored because I just think there's
so many silly mistakes that he should
have fixed but
he obviously loves
and so you can't argue with it and it's
like and that's all we wanted we want
somebody that genuinely
treats it like Star Trek and actually
does something that like I said I got up
every Thursday and I think he won't come
on this channel though I had an argument
with him on Twitter because I didn't
know who he was
I'm telling him oh please
yeah well he was it was about the Borg
and I said
um at the Picard season two
um and because how do you ruin the Borg
um they're the best villain in sci-fi
and you ruin them
um and I I kind of knew he was but I
didn't I hadn't actually like read him
up so I knew the name but I didn't know
quite why if you know to me
um but he he really argued he was really
offended and I just I just thought I was
talking to
you know somebody but he was because
obviously he'd written most episodes so
he got really offended and I was just
like but when I realized I was like I'm
so sorry I was just expressing my
opinion but he now he got offended so I
was like ah but you did ruin this
is why we should keep uh our negativity
to ourselves and focus on the positive I
didn't think I was being negative I just
thought I was expressing an opinion
um that they'd been neutered by
I just I just thought the whole end into
Picard season two was again if I'd have
realized who he was I wouldn't have said
it because it's because it'd be like
it's like somebody selling you saying
your kid's ugly
it doesn't matter if that's the ugliest
kid on the planet you're going to get
offended and you should
um so he was damn right to like be not
happy at me I'm not gonna I'm not saying
I was in the wrong completely I'm
actually really happy with um
you know the Borg started with Picard
and Q and
um
I thought it was a little odd in
hindsight hindsight's 2020 in hindsight
season two of Picard being all about
sort of the end of the Borg threat and
then season three being again about the
Borg threat uh it's like okay the boring
the Borg the Borg we get at the board uh
they became overused
um I think that uh but what what I liked
about
season three Picard is that moment where
Picard said all right
this is where we end this thing that
started 35 years ago yeah
um that I liked I think tying up the
Borg
the Q and the Picard plot lines all in
one sort of moment was
what should have happened and they
almost did it right yeah absolutely and
there was yeah I think I should start
disappointing to the season two because
and also I realized that was David
Goldsmith and he's very famously said I
don't want to do a show that my wife
won't want to watch
and it's like well then why the are
you doing Star Trek if your wife doesn't
want to watch Star Trek then you're not
gonna do a show that your wife won't
watch then why are you doing Star Trek
uh I'll just talk in Los Angeles was not
fun for me
yeah
it was not fun to watch uh the actors in
Picard season 2 are all great and uh
there were some really great stuff in
season two but first episode
again
damn it it's like a hawk it's like a
hack made Mirror Mirror Universe
yeah I don't know okay well they built
it up as well it was going to be all
about q and it was going to explain the
the whole thing between q and accounts
and and Q was barely in it and what he
was in it I'm thinking this whole thing
I'm not sure this whole series makes any
sense just gone it's me calm down we've
got a problem we're gonna go sort I'll
explain the book thing out later then
that whole series would have just been
one episode and it would go okay
um it just didn't it made no sense that
girati attacked in the first place yeah
um the whole thing and then all of Q's
actions didn't really make any sense and
that was what my problem with it was I'm
just watching the whole series thinking
it's like watching She-Hulk and get to
the end we go
there was no point to any of that
um it doesn't matter how good it is
there's no point to it and Rio Captain
Rios was my favorite character and then
they left him in the 21st and then they
left him in the past I love him
if if you get an actor to come back for
Stargate should be him he's awesome yeah
I love him
um thank you so much Mark for for coming
on and doing this I'm gonna go to bed
now and then anytime I'm a fan of your
show
um so I would love you to come back and
we will definitely
definitely have you back anytime you
want and so we've got any time to
anything you want to talk about so um
and and obviously and I want to talk to
Connor because
he's on Stargate so I guess so you know
if you can get in his ear and just go
give that lad an hour it's fine
um obviously quite happy we've talked to
Dominic as well because he's British so
he'll know we'll get my jokes
well uh we'll work on getting them on uh
we'll do a segment with him well that
would be amazing it would be easier if
it happens on a day that we're recording
because we all we will have all the gear
already and they'll be on set already
and
if you could do something anything to be
honest
um I would work around you guys because
I think it you're right uplifting and
get the name of the shuttle pod show out
there as well not the shuttlepod podcast
which is very hard to say shuttlepod
show it's the shuttlepark show it's a
show much better
um but um it's a great show so everyone
should be watching thank you and it's a
brilliant brilliant format so yeah no
thank you very much
[Music]